Speaker 1: I don't know how many of you have been
following the anti-Semitic sort of troll group
that has been harassing Jewish folks
in Florida and in other parts of the
country. But I have absolutely fascinating
video of Volusia Sheriff Mike Chitwood.
Going nuclear on these neo-Nazi lunatics. This
is a very interesting video I'm going to play for
you. This was from just a few days ago, The Daily
Beast article about it explains A week after a
neo-Nazi hate group circulated through the Daytona
Beach, Florida, area, displaying and distributing
extremist propaganda, the county's top cop has had
enough. A seething Valukas Sheriff Mike Chitwood
held a press conference on Monday, said, This
isn't about free speech. This is about violence.
It is very, very much worth looking at this. Take
a listen. You'll first hear just a few seconds.
This is video from Vice News. A few seconds of
these so-called protesters just harassing Jewish
people. And then we'll hear from Sheriff Chitwood.
Speaker 8: Leave our country, go back to Israel.
Hey, you help jiu jitsu. Hey, you guys forced it
in your bag, Got on camera. Get your up. Back up,
back up. We are not going to tolerate this. Let me
tell you, this is not about free speech. This is
about violence. Two days after the incident
at the Speedway, one of these GDL members.
Speaker 1: Remember GDL means Goyim
Defense League. It's an anti-Semitic group.
Speaker 8: In shot two Jewish Orthodox folks
outside of their synagogue in L.A.. There's
a lot of people in this room and there's a lot of
people around this country of the Jewish faith who
are on their hitlist. They try to besmirch your
character. They try to put death threats out on
you, threaten you and your family. Yeah, well,
I wear that as a badge of honor because I, too,
by these clowns who want to shut my big mouth and
put a bullet in the back of my head. Good for you.
That's my message to you. Go for it. You came to
the wrong county. I stand with my Jewish friends,
and I'm honored to be on your hit list. It's
an honor to be to be sought after by a bunch of
punk folks like you. That's my personal message.
With that, turn it over to people around the call.
Speaker 1: More people will now be allowed to
speak. Listen. Good. Good for this guy. And this,
of course, alone isn't actually going to shut
these clowns down. But the part of the problem is
it gets some attention. These clowns get some
attention and the videos sort of go viral,
but then it doesn't get the same serious
handling that some other things do. And
as the sheriff points out, it's very easy to
say, all right, they're standing outside of
a dairy mart with a sign about Jews. But it goes
beyond that and it gets to it becomes real world
violence. And we see examples of it. So good
for the sheriff. More folks should be aware
of the fact that these troll groups are harassing
people who are or who they believe to be Jewish,
and sometimes they're just wrong. Sometimes they
harass people who aren't even Jewish. Not that
it matters, but it just sort of like, by the way.
And if more sheriffs and if law enforcement dealt
with it more the way Sheriff Chitwood is, we
would probably all be far better off. So good
for him. We have a YouTube channel, YouTube.com
slash The David Pakman Show, which I would love
for you to subscribe to. It's free to do. And we
also have a Spanish YouTube channel which you can
find at David Pakman dot com slash Spanish,
whichever of the two languages you prefer to
consume progressive political analysis in it is
available to you. And that's a beautiful thing.